we're gonna skate the one song one song
only how many people in this auditorium
have no idea of Who I am
raise your hands that hurts that hurts
that hurts that [ __ ] hurts I'm gonna
take a few minutes to give you context
of where I come from and then we can go
into the steel I was born in Belarus the
former Soviet Union Soviet Union Soviet
Union
I came to America when I was 3 years old
and I was extremely poor as you could
imagine my family lived in history new
apartment in Queens New York in Queens
New York my dad got a job at a liquor
store getting paid $2 an hour and that
and that and that and that and that and
that's where our American dream started
I was always a business kid salesman
salesman's salesman when I was 14 my dad
dragged me into the liquor store that he
owned and I went from making $1000 a
weekend to making two bucks two bucks
two bucks bagging ice I call those [ __ ]
[ __ ] years you know I I thought that I
was gonna open up a hundred liquor
stores a hundred wine stores across
America sell it sell it sell it I the
New York Jets you sell it you sell it
sell it buy the New York Jets I buy the
New York Jets my the New York Jets my my
business and life goals who couch
old-school dial-up internet who cool
old-school dial-up internet who couch
all right and about five or six minutes
and to ever seeing the Internet I said I
think I can sell Chevelle who's L sell
[ __ ] I decided by that night that I no
longer needed to open a thousand liquor
stores I was gonna fix big thing a
singer figure this thing out in 1996 I
launched Wine Library calm calm calm
calm which was the second ecommerce wine
business in the United States 1996 that
site doing eight hundred and fifty
dollars in sales to 1998 there was a
three million dollar business and in a
five year window from 98 2003 from 98
2003 I grew that business from a
three to a 60 million dollar business
thank you thank you